yo I wonder like you sitting back and
kind of seeing cuz we talked about how
like you know for whatever reason the
bay gets overlooked when we think of
like stories and how you know it gets
covered I mean I think lately
unfortunately most of the stuff we hear
about the bay in the news world like
Nationwide is real negative you know
what I'm saying it's [__] up out
here whether it's the the smash and grab
or the the bippin or you know whatever
the case is for you like what do you
think is you know cuz cuz if you go
through the city if you go in San
Francisco it's a lot of different place
than it was even 5 years ago four years
ago you know what I mean like for you
what do you think is um the remedy and
what do you think is the cause of kind
of all the the chaos in in in the bay
right now man it's going to be a touchy
subject bro but I'm just going to be
real bro because at the end of the day
I'm not I didn't make it this far to
stay silent about things I think they
just let the city go to [__] on purpose
they jent fired the [__] out of San
Francisco they moved all the people that
are from there out of there so actual
care and love is not really there
anymore from people that grew up in
neighborhoods like Hunter point or you
know Lake View or the Filmore District
or the mission they just moved everyone
out they brought big Tech in big Tech
got spoiled they got you know they they
started turning the city into what they
want to even the neighborhood I grew up
in on California and Filmore my dad's
restaurant used to be on top of our on
the bottom of our apartment complex and
then there would be like a movie store
there' be
pizza shop there' be a coffee shop
there' be this Mexican restaurant it's
all Boutique clothing stores right I was
like who the [__] what the [__] this
ain't a neighborhood no more this is
some like highend techy [__] and so I
think the biggest problem with SF is
that it got gentrified and they got way
too liberal like bro I like how liberal
de Bay Area is I grew up getting money
because of the laws of how liberal it is
but buto They smash and grab [__] some
some chump ass [__] bro and like the
fact they just let it ride like that
like the fact you can walk into
Walgreens and just take whatever you
want and walk out and not worry about
going to jail that day it's [__]
because at the end of the day bro we got
kids and I want my kids to feel safe
when they go do their thing in the city
you would like if your daughter was 18
19 cuz she's getting there right she 16
yeah you know you would not feel
comfortable with her going shopping by
herself in San Francisco I send somebody
with her because I know what it is I
know that there's a risk for her car to
get broken into I know there's a risk
for someone to steal something out of
her hand and just move and so this is
the Bay Area y'all we grew up selling
tax getting money out of [__] we grew
up you know doing what we had to do
we're real Hustlers we're this the home
with the independent blueprint you for
sure E40 JT the bigger figure we own our
own masters we we were taught how to
hustle from our mouthpiece I feel like
that's where I am where I am in life is
because I was bred by the real ones with
real game bring it back to that dude go
pick up go go get back with this [__]
man go hate to say it as a father of a
of a Teenage one bro go break a [__] go
go go sell a pack go go build an
independent [__] portfolio of music
go go do something dope man like all
this other shit's hella Petty it just
it's trash and like that's not what we
represent I see some big players
speaking out on it some real ones that
did a lot of time out of the Oakland
area shout out to l d you know shout out
to the real ones the real players we're
players in the Bay Area we're go-getters
we're independent husters we're we're a
different breed than anyone else let's
put that respect back on the area
because right now we look like a bunch
of little petty ass thieves and that's
not what it is you know it's crazy I
have this talk all the time cuz you know
I'm a I'm a [__] pretty liberal dude
you know like I voted Democrat most of
my life my whole life me too um and you
know it's
like it's like at what point in time
it's like yo what what are we doing I
feel like they're getting too liberal
bro they're letting this [__] fall and
this is my zero Bale [__] like it's like
that's coming to La October 1st I'm like
y'all think La is bad right now yeah but
let me tell you why though I'm I'm a I'm
a preach man I feel like they're doing
this [__] on purpose so they can
Implement other laws that way supersede
any of this [__] so y'all can get away
with some [__] right now keep
[__] up our program keep making us
look crazy and they're going to come
they're going to come in and be like you
know what due to all these problems
we're going to put in this law right
here that's boom boom boom boom boom
we're going to be like whoa so
everyone's you might have to show like
your scan your ID before you even enter
a mall soon it just I feel like China's
leading the way for like the social
credit score [__] they're leading the
way for like this
non real lifestyle like they're
monitoring they're the real big brother
right now and I feel like what they're
doing in the US especially in in in
Democratic areas is they're letting this
[__] fall apart on purpose so they can
Implement bigger laws that just affect
and take all of our freedom away that's
just my opinion I could be high maybe
guys I been smoking a little too much at
the end of the day there is something to
be said about like that social credit
score [__] because it already kind of
feels like it's happening like [__] yeah
it's happening look at Instagram dog you
you act wrong you speak about something
they don't want you to speak about you
get
shadowbanned they tell you we're only
showing your content to XM my why who's
deciding this [__] that's that big
brother [__] that's why you should join
Social Club [__]